i am gabby degusto my name is chingus my
name is oyenda ajayi i'm a student here
at the gsb i would describe the academic
experience at gsp as truly multifaceted
it is both theoretical and practical at
once it is applied but also abstract it
is scholarly
but at the same time quite feelings and
emotions based the academic experience
here really starts with building a
foundation in core business skill sets
all of those things that will make you a
much more successful manager in the end
so i think one of the things that's
really great about the stanford graduate
school of business is that we recognize
that great leaders are both analytical
and intuitive at the same time that to
really build great organizations that
are going to change the world you have
to be able to combine these two very
different skills you need the rigor
of a scientist you need to be able to
break down the world into analytical
pieces and understand how those
different moving parts fit together
at the same time you need the creativity
of the artist and the insight and the
vision
that is required to see things that
haven't existed yet i find it quite
interesting because there's a lot of
code switching going on where in one
class i might be using kind of the right
side of my brain in another class might
not be really using my brain but using
my heart instead and kind of those code
switchings of what part of my skill set
and talents and mental frameworks am i
supposed to stretch has been a really
really fulfilling and interesting
experience in a way in which i didn't
think that it would be
at the gsb we don't believe there's only
one right way to teach in the classroom
you're going to encounter lectures
you're going to encounter case studies
you're going to encounter simulations
you're going to encounter role plays
you're going to encounter experiential
learning all of these different
varieties of teaching and learning are
such a critical part of what the gsb
education is about each professor
approaches it differently so there are a
lot of simulations there are a lot of
experiential courses there's also a lot
of classes that focus on the case study
and so each one pushes you in a
different way the experiential side of
it gives you an opportunity to now test
out some of the things you've learned in
class and speaking to people and then
the small group allows you to get
feedback one-on-one from your pair and
be able to dig deeper into your own
personal growth who teaches you really
matters you're going to learn from both
world-class researchers and from leading
business executives and we're going to
bring them together and their interplay
with each other is really what's going
to make you understand the craft of
leadership here at the gsb we have both
professors who are tenured professors so
professors who their career is really
based on research as well as people who
are coming in from the field and have
companies or they run funds and so
having the two come together is hugely
valuable i think learning from academic
researchers is important because you see
the numbers behind behaviors you see why
the decisions are being made and you're
able to make certain decisions or
come to certain conclusions more
concretely because you have information
to back it on the practitioner side of
the equation i love to hear from the
people who have been out there and have
actually done these things to tell us
about their mistakes and about their
regrets and about what they did best i
think fundamentally the experience of
being a student here is transformational
students come in thinking that they're
going to do one thing with their lives
and they come out a totally different
person and that's a product of what they
learn in the classroom it's a product of
what they learn from their fellow
students it's a product of what they
learn from their faculty members it is
an amazing transformational experience
to be here at the gsb you think about
the world differently once you have been
here and you are positioned to go out
and do really great things for students
who are yet to come and be a part of our
wonderful jsp community the academic
program is quite rigorous i would say
coming in with the expectations that you
will be learning a lot and it will be a
lot in the best way for anyone thinking
of business school as a next step i
would say absolutely do it you cannot
imagine the amount of growth and
opportunities that come with this
experience